thank you Mike so welcome this is a talk
about an issue i was working on for the
last three four years the parts of my
group is computational social choice
this is a theme which is maybe not so
common in the theory crowd most studies
are published rather in AI settings but
so that's also why I will start with a
short motivation for the whole area and
what it is about and where does it come
from I don't know where it's going to
but let's see what there are some
interesting problems so it's about
social choice mechanisms and egg
rhythmic decision making and the most
important topic maybe for us we were
doing this talk will be voting problems
but closely related our rank aggregation
fair division matching so you know
stable matching maybe and with those
allocation problems of course these
topics overlap and as mentioned before
artificial intelligence people are
working a lot on this area and there are
other areas like operations research
discrete math and of course also
theoretical computer science and on the
non math side so to say our political
sciences economics and so on okay the
long-term goal is to do something useful
of course and maybe the closest friend
in terms of what people in this field
are doing is sometimes they also do some
work on a rhythmic game theory okay so
maybe just to drop a few names of
problems that appear in this context and
i will discuss a few in my talk
gerrymandering i will come to this later
it's about political districting and
other thing is winner determination if
you have votes then you want to know who
is winning the election sometimes this
is trivial like for plurality voting
sometimes it's auntie heart like 4k mini
voting a problem which typically turns
out much harder is the determination of
possible and necessary with us that's
when have partial boats and partially
information and you want to know for
instance whether your favorite candidate
still is has a chance to win at least so
maybe this will influence your behavior
okay a more recent topic is proportional
representation this is also voting but
its voting of committees so and in this
goal at context the goal sometimes maybe
that you want to have a fair
representation of the whole population
so representing different dreams or
different qualifications also maybe in a
committee in a company and there are
some evil topics as well like
manipulation control and bribery and
these are particular interest to us
because they are nice and P heart
problems in this context my experience
from the last few years is that fpt
related studies here are very natural
they are number of very natural
parameterizations for instance a simple
one is the number of candidates in some
elections you have you elect candidates
in other elections you have few voters
for instance in human research human
resource departments you have many
people's applying people applying for a
job and a few of decision-makers is
writing about the candidates so you have
few voters many candidates both can be
small in certain applications okay
before I move on I want to give you a
very recent example of a problem we
worked on its in on deriving from
parliamentary voting so how you vote
inside a parliament so actually this
topic was brought up by one of my co of
us Toby Walsh from Australia he is a top
expert in AI and also in computational
social choice so this is real world in
the sense of it goes back to nineteen
fifty-six well you could vote over free
alternatives or Parliament could vote
over these bas it doesn't really matter
what the vote is about so you can read
it but so let's assume and this is now
made up we have
android voters who prefer a number
alternative p to alternative s and the
least liked one is alternative a and
let's also assume you have another
hundred voters that have a different
preference list top position is always
the most like one last position is the
least liked one and we have one special
water and in this context of sequential
voting or parliamentary voting you have
something additional which is not so in
other voting problems and that's the
agenda and that somehow in in a way how
the candidates are processed and there's
a difference between the ural latin
world and the next one will be the angle
American one and the good news for being
here is that there I would clearly
recommend the angular American procedure
to the lube Latin one so let's see so
these are used in Parliament decisions
inside Parliament so let's assume so the
new Latin procedure sometimes also
called the successive procedure is like
this so you start in the front position
first alternative and compared with the
rest the rest is a and s and you ask
yourself by maturity vote thus be des be
beat a and F together so begets hundred
votes a and s together get 101 volts so
it doesn't beat it so it loses so we
continue with this and then you proceed
to the next position and compare a to
the rest okay the rest noise only s and
so you finally see a will win this and
if sorry no a will not win but as well
as will we know of course yeah sorry
ucs beats a s bjs and only in one case
it doesn't okay the angular American
procedure sometimes also called the
amendment procedure works like this so
you only compare the two top positions
which have not been compared yet so you
compare b2a and check who is in front in
the majority of the world and in this
case it is be that clearly wins against
a so we would continue in this direction
and then compare be with s and finally
be wins so you see depending on the
agenda and the procedure it it you have
different alternatives winning and so
natural questions now you could ask
yourself you have seen maybe the agenda
plays are an important role who will win
this and so it means also the power of
say the head of the parliament in which
order he or she sets up the agenda and
this is one of these problems related to
this fine Anna and gender such that your
preferred candidate a win's how can you
set the agenda and let's consider an
example so let's only have free voters
with these preferences or go to one
likes a Mosby last and so on can you
find an agenda such that avians so you
have to order the candidates touch that
avians do you have a proposal how it
works that a wins so you're lettin was
the first is compared to the rest of the
pack
oh we should give it till the enterprise
but yeah yeah you shift it to the end
and it's basically you see it pops up in
the final comparison and in the American
anglo-american procedure you would have
a different agenda to make a mean okay
so this one of these problems to further
problems that make sense in this context
is of course if you're in the parliament
you have to talk about manipulation so
manipulation in voting context usually
is to add votes in order to make your
preferred candidate a again win assuming
that we have already a fixed agenda
which is part of the input in this case
and a second kind of problems you would
study as I mentioned already before as
possible winner let's focus on this
necessary somehow the complement in that
way so you have an election where you
have incomplete preferences and an
incomplete agenda and you want to know
whether you can do that still can win by
completing in it in a favorable way so
and just to give you a flavor of what
you typically then do I mean you study
this problems and actually as you see so
these two markings mean that they are
from previous work not over so agenda
control and manipulation for both
procedures can be done in polynomial
time it seems to be a bit easier for the
viewer letting thing and actually this
is also confirmed by practical
experiments with sort of real-world data
as far as they are available and
possible winner is in PR in both
contexts also in the weighted case and
it's already enough if you only have
three alternatives so free candidates to
vote on and somehow interesting is the
necessary winner cases for the angular
America and one is still hard co NT
hardware is its polynomial-time solvable
for your Latin procedure and as I said
we also perform some experiments and
from this the clear recommendation also
intuitively
the anglo-american seems more reasonable
and it's also if you see how easily it
can be manipulated or so it's clearly
speaks against the euro Layton one which
is in use okay so this was just to
motivate what sort of problems we are
looking at and so back to my general
motivation if you are interested in this
this comic world is easily to enter and
the best way is to attend one of these
workshops the next one will be next year
in France and to lose so it's very legs
so if you submit a paper that it's
lightweight reviewing and it doesn't
count as a publication so every PhD
student can submit an even published
paper it's not too old of course sorry
just move more for meeting people and
discussing problems it has been present
in dark stall and the major publication
lane venues the top papers maybe a pH
replay I each chi è see this is more
fear we like the others are AI
conferences on a mess and there of
course also specific journals so maybe
the most specific one is the ACM
transactions on economics and
computation and AI shown us and the like
and there are also assurance between
math and social sciences like
mathematical social sciences where you
could publish this or social choice and
welfare okay about history on one slide
a social choice without computational
yeah it's a serious discipline since the
1950s with feelings made by people in
political science black and arrows have
two very famous fear in so instance but
in the 18th century you have two French
people who to propose some voting
systems condo sea and border both are
still in use where you already have some
say three studies of voting problems in
particular the computational side
started mainly with a series of papers
by but wholly to
we and trick or sometimes a lean and
basically they applied computational
complexity to study some traditional or
basic voting problems and they showed
that some of them are in P heart for
sometimes with a determination for
specific voting rules which are of
course more interesting than just low
relative voting that's trivial because
you trust to counting SPV will it's
sometimes used in the US and also about
manipulation controlling an election or
three okay and you could say since now
thirteen years this is an active
research area in this community with the
workshop exists since 2006 and there's
also a mailing list you can join with
announcements in this community so it's
very open so this was now my motivation
part and now I want to start with a few
considerations mainly based on our own
work presenting a few problems and a few
interesting hopefully interesting
observations we made on lower bound
questions that could be of interest to
you we have three cases actually for the
lobbying problem i will stop really send
you in a minute and then we have some
private version and then we have
something different we bring also graph
into because we originated from prof
problems so we like to see graphs again
and so this is best seen when you do
politically districting or
gerrymandering as i mentioned before and
finally we also have something about
coalition formation which we call
maturity wise accepted bellowed okay so
now we come to lobbying lobbying
intuitively I guess you know what it
means in our context it will be a simple
matrix problem which I present here so
we are not the first to study this
problem also from our parameterize point
of view as you can see at the bottom
so basically you have a set of voters in
this case we have five voters and you
have a few issues here we have three
issues and each voter can approve or
disapprove this yes or no for each of
them so for both the one says no to
emissions trading no to a nuclear power
but yes to takes right arising the Texas
and so on and so it's clear so you get a
binary matrix and further we get a
number K as we always have in perimeter
eyes complexity and we ask ourselves can
we change at most K rows of this matrix
such that each column has more than also
sorry more once than zeros or more queen
stuff than red stuff which is so far not
the case of course of course by trivial
pre-processing we can assume without
loss of generality that our goal will be
to have all ones or green things here
and we assume all current so far right
because columns that already green you
have nothing to do so we can skip them
or delete them okay and so this is the
lobbyists goal and so in our case it's
not so hard to see what you would have
to manipulate so if you change the first
and the last voters row so setting these
zeros to one's actually then you get the
maturity of once in each okay
manipulation is making a whole roll is
that's the definition of course you can
have many variations of it this the
simplest version there's also a weighted
version and so on and so forth sometimes
it would like enough to just yeah but
this makes the problem significantly
harder actually so okay i start with the
only eth based thing I can talk about
and this is actually a more or less
trivial so this is just the definition
again and this okay a trivial solution
of the problem is
what can you do if you have n rows and
voters you can try all 2 to the n
possibilities whom to change and check
whether this is giving you an all one
maturity in all columns ok so it's
trivial available in this time and can
we do better and what you can observe I
will have its a reduction from vertex
cover and it's more or less standard
it's not so well known but it's an easy
reduction and by this simple reduction
you already get the disks doesn't
totally more or less optimal so you
cannot do better and actually the
reduction I don't want to go into it but
just you you go as you start from a
graph and look at the incidence matrix
so you have numbers these are the edges
and these the rows are the vertices and
you add a little stuff which is not very
hard to do but you should not look into
the details right now and basically then
you can reduce vertex cover to this
problem and you get the lower bound from
the vertex cover lower bound so it's
nothing deep it's just a simple
observation more less ok
okay so the second thing is also for
this problem it's fairly easy to do but
this is a standard thing for I would say
thousands of working problems where you
this famous result you to length with
some small improvements later which
basically says if you have an integer
linear program where the number of
variables is the parameter then you can
solve it in fpt time so this is and this
is a maybe the most important tool for
showing apt results in voting especially
for harder problems where the parameters
the number of columns or the number of
alternatives the candidates the number
of candidate okay and as I said using
this and we don't know any other way and
this is true for 20 40 other problems I
know where we only know how to do it
with Leinster and no other way and one
of my open problems would be is there
any chance to get a direct combinatorial
equation for any of these problems and
this is just a simple case what we could
show there is no polynomial kernel with
respect to them angely combined
parameter M number of columns and the
number of rows per and a number of
modified rules sorry okay so these are
already my ball my questions I mentioned
and this is basically the ILP trust you
give you a flavor of it so this but the
simple idea is ok if you have a limited
number of alternatives which can be said
on or off then you have at most 2 to the
M many different variables reflecting
everywhere type of row you can have yeah
if you have em positions and everyone
can be 0 or 1 so you have 2 to the M
types of roles you can have and of
course then the only thing that matters
is how many of these you have the
multiplicity of these and this is this
bound r RI so this gives you an upper
bound for our this gives you the bound
and so what you want is to select a
specific number of at most
our I many of these roles in order which
you want to change so basically what the
problem is selecting rose you want to
make the old ones rolls right and from
each type you can choose that most are a
are many okay that's one thing and the
other thing is I even don't want to go
into the detail intuitively this line
tells you okay but each column has a gap
which it has to meet in order to get a
maturity of ones and this is this number
g g j and what you have to have you have
to meet this gap for each column so and
how can you meet it you can only meet it
if you selected a row what a zero has
been set to one that's why it's called a
bar because we are interested in the
entries where so far was a zero if there
was already a one then modifying this
road to the old one row doesn't help you
so it's quite straightforward actually
and yeah so you see what we at the end
of the day what we have is a an ILP
where we hear the number of variables is
basically two to the N and then we use
lenses machinery and we can solve it and
if you plug in the most recent or the
best-known at least to me best-known
upper bounds you have such an upper
bound and this is not nice and it's
widely open whether you can any get
anything better ya better upper bounds
or you can give or you can develop some
interesting lower bounds may be an
interesting thing again for this we not
obvious but not hard to implement greedy
heuristic actually gives in linear time
an optimal solution for up to four
alternatives which is sometimes
sufficient in some applications and a
nonlinear time but Christy greedy her if
they gives you an approximation agree
for if is logarithmic in n
and both of these algorithms work very
well in practice there almost always in
most real-world instances they basically
give already the optimal solution in our
cases from our practical side this
problem is not as hard if you have no
combinatorial fpt ray griffin with
respect to the parameter m okay this is
just what I said already so the general
thing is about these ILP fpt results for
voting problems it's typically always
works the same way you have a type of
objects in the solution and you can bind
bound on the number of types by the
parameter by a function of the parameter
and only the number of the objects is
important and so this means it's works
easier if the objects are unweighted of
course because then they are
indistinguishable and we have some
linear constraints that we can express
our problem and this works very nicely
and very recently in this is just a side
remark we also actually mainly it was
due to Peter's cover on from Russell who
who somehow discovered that you can
somehow extend the power of this by
solving more voting problems you can
also allow nonlinear convex constraints
where the variables don't have to be
integer by basically again using the
lens imaginary which actually works for
mixed LPS if you look at it and what
what was on the for the theory crowd
that what you could show why this is
that the weighted set multi cover which
is just your weights and multi cover
means you may have to cover one element
or one set more than once getting back
that you can show it's an FPT time using
this and based on this there are some
voting problems approval based by
primary problems where you can show for
the first time thing I fpt by using this
sort of extension
of the standard IP framework due to
Leinster okay so maybe I I believe may
be the most interesting part to you
could be this one now because I'm also
outside voting I know little where the
parameterize people looked at this class
log S&P and it helped us to classify
sort of the parameterize complexity of
lobbying with respect to the parameter
the maximum gap you have remember you
want to have a majority of once in each
column and maybe you have 20 or 21 roles
and you have several seven ones in the
specific column then they get put before
because you need for more ones to get
the maturity of 11 and the maximum for
all columns lets this gap value and this
is of course a natural parameter usually
you only would do lobbying if it's not
you don't have to influence too many
people if you're already close to your
goal so get considering the gap would be
quite natural and to be a small
parameter okay and if a simple heuristic
which works as follows this is only I
only use it now for convincing you that
sort of the certificate I need to do to
solve this problem parameterize by G is
relatively small actually it's of this
size it's over of T times log square in
input size n plus M models and this one
too aristocratic it does the very simple
thing it always takes a role filled with
at least half with zeros if you think
about the problem for a short while it's
very clear if this would not exist then
we could already simplify our instance
so assuming that there is a gap greater
than or at least one of at least one
that has to be a rover at least
of the entries are filled with zeros and
we just take this one in a greedy
fashion as you see and make them not the
old one thing so we make progress on
this and if you do this repeatedly you
can see after I don't want to go into
the details after these many steps you
will have a small arm you have will have
decreased you get by at least one now
it's not completely trivial but it's
nothing deep so after a logarithmic
number of rounds G times logarithm then
you will see the number of ones has
increased ok and so since we can decree
a identify or yeah identify each row by
logarithmic number of bits so we know we
need only so many rows and this is the
number of which we need to specify the
bit so we know there's a certificate of
this size and now brute-forcing over all
possible certificates gives you an egg
griffin running basically in this
running time so into the g times log n
plus 1 and we're going to Jose here yeah
so now for us the question was what is
now the complexity of lobbying and what
we what we could see is that lobbying
from the following result lobbying is
not in XP with respect to the parameter
G so it's not an XP and on the other
side it's also not para NP hard for
constant G and so this was a bit strange
because it's somehow in between and the
answer then was this last lock is in p
which is about class of bounded
non-determinism you know p is and NP of
course and log p lockers in peace
basically more or less it's actually a
subclass but more or less for us it's
enough to know it basically what you can
solve with a logarithmic square number
of non deterministic bits so this is the
class introduced by papa
view on Dianna carcass and they all
there's also the concept of la caisse NP
completeness it's a bit technical but
maybe the most useful problem you should
know from this context where you have to
reduce to or from depending on what you
want to show complete net containment or
hardness and we showed both using this
problem so which hypergraph cover and
it's more or less like it's the
following so you have a base at the
universe and then even and off which
contains an even number of elements and
here subsets of these universe and each
of the industry's why it's called which
we each of the set set contains at least
half of the elements of your universe
and what you are asking is now whether
there is a subset of the universe which
touches all of these subsets and head
size at most K and this is maybe the
most useful location P complete problem
we know of and so what we could do is
reduce our problem to this rich
hypergraph cover and also because we use
rich hypergraph cover to our problem
showing that the problem lobbying
parameterize by the gap parameter is
location P complete okay and basically
that's small as the only example I know
for a natural parameterize problem which
is location fee complete so it could be
a useful tool for showing for
classifying the complexity of other
problems in parameterize complexes
lying between power and P hardness and
XP okay we are coming to bribery now
though so it's bribery which we are
looking at their different versions of
primary and so let's assume we have the
following situation so we have voters
again three countries and devote on
symphonies by four different composers
from four different countries and so you
see different preferences again a is the
most like one DS the least like one and
the winner is computed border top-ranked
symphony so I didn't explain what border
means but it's very simple it's almost
what is used in European song contest
almost this means let's do it like this
if you're in top position you get 3
points 2 points 1 point 0 points so it's
a positional boasting system so this
means candidate a gets six points
because it's in top position twice and
last position once and so on okay and I
doing them off you see that arm swings
so far and the goal now is may you have
a different candidate you would prefer
let's make see the winner and how you
can make it is you can shift candidates
to the front by bribing the respective
voters so the shift properiy problem
coming back to this one you are given
such an election like this you are given
a specific preferred candidate and you
what you also have you have some prices
what it costs you to shift forward into
the respective folders your candidate
and of course you have a budget and
typically you want to minimize your
costs
you want to reach your goal with the
given budget and such a shift action
then would what we search for is a shift
action and this basically is how you
shift to the front how many positions us
be preferred candidate in each rotor and
the overall cost should be bounded by
the budget you have okay and the rule is
sort of parameter we considered here the
border rule a scoring base draw but you
can consider this problem for 20 other
voting rules which are on the market and
what we could show for this is that and
this is somehow nice because very
recently we also could show it's w1 hard
so we have a very strong approximation
algorithm for this parameterize
approximation algorithm which gives you
a factor 1 plus epsilon approximation in
fpg time more precisely the running time
is this so it's in exponential in n and
epsilon and roughly what is I mean this
is a not so difficult a Griffin but
again this is one of the simplest
examples we have there are more
intricate one but my general observation
is that in the voting context there's
quite a lot of room for fpt
approximation algorithms and actually
even approximation schemes which
probably you would even implement in
applications and in this context
basically what you do is what makes the
road what you have to do is somehow
scaling down the costs so you have to
pay something for each candidate you
want for each voter you want to bribe
and to make the costs small and then do
some pre brute forcing more or less does
the job that's what small as written
here I don't want to go into the details
but it's not extremely hard to get this
with this scaling of the prices for
shifting
and maybe one more slide so this was a
very positive result and when you
generalize this problem so typically
people who are on the positive side of
primary they call it campaign management
campaign management means the same as
bribery but it means it has a more
positive flavor because it as you do in
political campaigns you give information
to people so that they change their
votes in you're in favor of what you
want of course and so the system yeah so
you if you open this paper some of them
are called blah blah blah campaign
management sometimes they have in the
title bribery depending on how you want
to solve and if you do a campaign and
that's what the company will not even
define it blowed belly in but the
combinatorial stands for is if you say
you have a spot on TV then you cannot
directly say it only affects one person
but it sets a group of person may be
connected by a social network that's the
combinatorial flavor so and sometimes
maybe if you do a TV spot you will
positively influence some voters and
negatively will influence other voters
because depending on their political
opinions and if you take this into
account you end up at something which we
call combinatorial chef bribery which is
a generalization of the one you just saw
before and the point here is this
problem is of course harder and may be
of interest is we have it's completely
in approximate the unless FP t equals W
to you cannot approximate it to any
factor
this is only true if the problem reaches
the realistic thing is where you can
have negative effects so if you have a
TV spot as I mentioned before a negative
effect is if you somehow someone seeing
this effect even gets upset and really
downgrades your candidate but of course
others are will upgraded it okay that's
about bribery and approximations so now
I have to explain this figure so I come
now to gerrymandering so this is a
historical drawing from 18 March 1812
and this is a cartoon I have to read it
modest which has been drawn in reaction
to newly drawn state election
distractions of South Essex by the
method ruthless government to favor the
democratic republican party's candidates
of governor elbridge Gary Gary this is
why it's called gerrymandering the first
part is the name of a governor of that
time who did this redistricting in favor
of the candidates of his party to win
the election so you just do new
consistencies and so and why is it men
de because this looks like a salamander
and so they the second part is men de so
gerrymandering is one thing and there
are other men during because but this is
the first one yeah you see they are in
this cartoon they somehow complain how
strange this formation of this new
district is just to make specific
candidate and gerrymandering is not
directly voting but it's also a comb
sock problem of course you need somehow
information of course about how your
voters in the different districts would
we would vote
okay so we we somehow invented some
motivated by this I'm graph problem
which somehow at least resembles what is
asked hear it you can also motivated by
storage updates applications in computer
science but maybe that's not so nice so
let's consider the following we have
given districts with only two voters so
it has to be simple so these are our
five districts each of one ka so its
nodes in a vertex at the end of the day
each of these districts contains to
voters and the goal is to increase the
number of voters bit per district by
free so we have to because we are
running out of money we have to shrink
the number or to decrease the number of
districts we have and so merge them
again that's what we consider and
there's nice the site condition we take
into account is that you only can merge
two districts if they are neighboring
right so so you could move some of the
water from here to here which is some
sub part of the district but not from
here to here because it's not unable
okay so if you would like to dissolve
these three districts so this gives our
six votes six voters and so it free of
them here and three of them here so you
can do it for instance like this all
right just moving around the pebbles
around along the graph edges and so we
end up with our redistricted a thing
with only two districts each containing
five voters so that's the basic problem
so to find such a resolution are we
redistribution
okay okay so what you can easily observe
is now what we are trying to do is to
relate the complexity of the problem to
the size of the district in the
beginning and how they decide changes
and note our problem is very simple in
the sense of its hundred percent
symmetric at the beginning or districts
have the same number of votes and the
change this is the Delta how many new
voters you win for each new deserve each
district that survives is the same for
all of them and if you look at this
problem then you can see for this main
diagonal where you have s the original
size and the chain the change is the
same then it's polynomial x over because
it's easy to see that small as a perfect
matching problem and not so hard you get
some other NP hardness problem NP
hardness results and an interesting
observation is a symmetry argument that
this following lemma it could show is
that they exist such an s Delta a
solution if and only if you change the
role of both of them and this gives you
half of the matrix because then you can
apply symmetry results you can s and
Delta s as is the original size and that
s is the change so you can sort of
exchange so he is roughly the argument
for this or here you see in the
beginning sizes s and the change is
Delta s is equal to free and and if you
change it to the opposite ss3 and their
days is now tool from the previous one
so you see just interchanging roles the
role of this civil dissolved in and
nandi sort of districts and what you do
is just reverting the arcs and in this
way you get the this symmetry and this
hour
ready feels as half of the table and
with some reduction from exact cover by
two-thirds which is not so easy than you
feel it all and so we have a complete
picture of the complexity of the problem
is only easy if the original district
size and the change is the same in
number actually from applications you
could this makes very much sense to look
at the planar case of this problem
because if you think about the
redistricting thing then you would say
okay this is small as a planar map and
actually hear the picture is incomplete
so you see a lot of question marks we
could not answer and what would help us
a lot is if you would know how how hard
this problem is Lena exact cover by tea
sets exact cover by Jesus I hope you
know you want to cover a ground set by
selecting subsets and so each element of
the ground set has to be covered it
exactly once that's the exact and he
says mean sighs tea sets and yeah we
don't know plainer than means you can
draw the incidence matrix between
subsets and the elements and if this
graph is planar we don't know whether
it's hard we first four arm why not but
for instance you know planar 3sat is
also NP hard but planar falls out this
polynomial so we don't know whether this
would have a lot to answer some of the
question marks here whether this problem
is harder or not ok this is this problem
and we continue now with my final
problem with which is somehow about
coalition formation which is quite
different lower bound flavor so let's
assume you are given a set of proposals
and a set of voters and they have
favored bellows bellows are just
sets of proposals the ones you like and
you're given an agenda sometimes also
called and hidden agenda which you want
to sort of push through so you would
like the set of proposals which are
contained in q+ to be approved by the
electorate and you ask yourself is there
a bailout queue with where q+ is a
subset of and it's again it's a subset
of p of the set of all proposals such
that every single voter accepts this
that is a majority of the proposals in
this payload are accepted by this water
because it's in his favorite in it
because it's in his face or her fellow
yeah so accept him always means we have
more than half of them so we are happy
so that's of course sort of artificial
definition and maturity so this is
unanimously and the only change if you
have mature device ballots is here you
have every single voter has to accept
and we only have a strict majority more
than half has to accept and the question
is how hard it is to find this q+ so
here's an example for five proposals p 1
2 p-5 for bailouts which can correspond
121 to the voters and here's the you can
droid as a matrix columns are the
pellets are other proposals and the rows
are the ballots and here so this means
both the one approves p2 p3 p4 and
disapproves p 1 and p 5
ok as you can easily observe the bailout
p1 p2 p3 would be accepted by all voters
but half of the voters like p5 less than
half of the voltage like p5 so the
question is now how can if you can
somehow if you are the one to make the
proposal what people have to vote on can
you hide p5 into something such such
that still the majority would approve it
that's the two questions we consider and
for instance you can do it by proposing
in this simple example just all of them
so they would accept still because
somehow p5 if they don't like it the
majority but still the maturity of
proposals is accepted yeah actually this
problem is somehow interesting and
seemingly quite hard because for one
thing so there's no monotonicity
property with respect to solution sizes
and what we could show is that the
problem is w hard with respect to the
parameter size of this parameter size of
the solution and so far this is quite
standard for unanimously accepted
bailout where everyone has to accept it
is quite standard but also taking the
reduction to independent dominating set
but may be interesting here now is for
the maturity wise case we could not get
this classification we only could show
w2 hardness and containment in the class
introduced by Mike and some co office
which is w2 where you don't have end or
gates but maturity gates so a symmetric
version of w2 and what we and it's
fairly easy to show it's contained in W
to maturity and it's w too hard and it's
an open question whether a w-2
maturities equals to w
so they spend with if this is equal then
we would have an exact classification of
the complexity of this problem
okay so let's show a more already close
to the concluding remarks come to these
so i would like to invite you if you are
interested in hard combinatorial
problems so there's a lot of things to
do for more theoretically oriented
people also in terms of lower bounds
there are very few lower bounds results
in the context of social choice problems
voting problems very little is known
here and in these problems you may have
graphed sometimes matrix matrix
modification problems many of them
touched permutations and so on and so
the maturity of results that are
published so far are sometimes w
hardness w completeness results para NP
hardness results or hardness for
constant parameter values and a few only
put no pony size Colonel results unless
the typically assumption ETH based lower
bounds are almost unknown in this area
or have not been considered yet and
maybe my general challenges deriving
from our work here is yeah so are there
any so I mentioned there are lots of
results in voting specifically when the
parameters the number of candidates
where you use length because I LP result
to show fpt so we actually don't know
any of these results where it was shown
by LT of length of it has been
transformed into a combinatorial a
Griffin but it should be possible for
some of them at least and also it's not
clear whether there are any lower bounds
I think people some people are working
on lower bounds and upper bounds
improving upper bounds for lenses LP
results this is of course coming from
another line but I'm not aware of there
any lower bound results for this what's
the best you can get okay the other
thing was log SNP which is the class of
bounded non-determinism so we used it as
a tool for classifying the lobbying
problem with respect to the parameter
the gap the number of missing ones in
each
color that was very helpful to get
something between para NP hardness and
XP which we before that could not
classify and yes as I mentioned last in
the last part is this whether this is
equal w2 is the same as W to maturity is
this is complete which contained in w to
maturity but the reverse directions
unknown and this goes back to Mike and
flume horn my fellows have your flume
Danny hameln mortgage Miller in friend
rosilyn from 2010 and another thing is
um maybe popped up already in one of the
talks so we in a in concert we have a
number of quite nice approximation
algorithms even approximation schemes
but are there any running time lower but
so these are typically fpt running times
but for these we don't have any lower
bounds how can we improve on the running
time of these fpt approximation schemes
1 plus epsilon approximations and yes if
you want to start in this area these are
some general introduction publications
in more or less recent ones this one is
the oldest one but it's still very
readable together 10 or 15 pages
overview of the field and to get the
feeling what a problem sample okay so
that's it thank you
any question about the practice or
social choice fielding influencing in
summary the practice of how social
choice is really done yes actually it's
a very good question in my opinion it's
always was always hard to understand by
this social choice publications most of
them I nai conferences because i would
say ninety percent of these are purely
theoretical and few of them do practical
experiments so I would so far we did a
few experiments but it was not so easy
to get some real data I guess the most
promising area is for instance where all
the companies want to elect committees
so to represent the set of voters and
this is something just starting now but
I found would say most of the results
are very theoretical maybe there could
be more impact but one one fundamental
problem in voting there's the trivial
voting system that's plurality voting
you have one vote for the topmost
candidate and you cannot express
anything about the rest but that's used
many times but most problems he are
completely trivial and if you will
propose more sophisticated voting
schemes the problem is the voters would
not accept it because they don't
understand it and if you don't
understand how the voting works they
would not use it that's a weakness of
the community but I think there is
potential
so I like to refresh it are you seeing
political consultants and guys over food
try running for election showing up at
comstock actually there are people of
course from political science but so far
no one from really making business out
of it no at least not that you could
recognize them I regularly attend
conferences or workshops where there are
government officials algorithms people
semantics people editions cryptographers
and so on actually do have an origin I
can change changed voting rules for
entire countries so this is a really
high impact area the consequences for
yet nations maybe one remark in this
context one topic over here is also
resource allocation I think this is also
a hot theme because I mean you could say
many problems where political leaders
are fighting with is now say pollution
or water resources how to fairly
distribute them and to develop some
mechanisms but this also has some
overlap of course with a terrific game
theory to to get some fair resources
education whatever fair means but you
have many different context where this
comes into play committee elections are
also a resource allocation problem
because you allocate to the resource of
being in the committee which decides on
something you also want to have a fair
representation not only of the majority
but of all kinds of people opinions
sexist racist whatever
I'm talking about the lobbying problem
where you have to choose the K rows to
change in order to get a majority of
one's age column yep that's w hard you
showed its w too hot yeah to show you
can't do it in the end a little okay I
did not think about it so maybe yes I
mean as I said there's basically almost
nothing from the eth well that so far
made it into this so there are not so
many theory people working on these
problems most of them have an IA I
background and I only wouldn't know a
handful or ten people who know about fpt
concepts but once you tell them what it
means they like it direct from
dominating set and I mistake natural
show this do wasn't it from independent
dominating set I don't know
the same bro